das wichtigste thema kommt traditionell
zum schluss sofern danke ich für das
sofort vertrauen das ihr
entgegengebracht worden ist ich wollte
mich darüber nicht mehr aufregen aber
über dinge die man einfach nicht mehr
ausweichen kann indem man eklatant
anderer meinung ist muss man sich
aufregen in den letzten 24 stunden habe
ich einen brief bekommen erstens von
meiner bank da stand drin liebe
alexander kissler für dich als kunst
sternchen haben wir ein neues angebot
also man hat aus meiner als resse und
meinem geschlecht beschlossen dass ich
vielleicht einen grund sternchen in bin
danach am nächsten tag hat die
katholische kirche abschluss gehabt
ihrer sogenannten synodale versammlung
da gab es anträge die alle durch
geändert waren bis zur absurdität es
halt einmal drin ist auch gut dass so
viele frauen sternchen professorinnen
sternchen geworden sind daran sieht man
diese gender sprache wenn also sterne in
hauptwörter hinein regnen ist sinnlos
denn man will ja sagen frauen wurden
professorinnen wenn frauen sternchen auf
männer sein können ist der satz ja
völlig sinnlos und drittes beispiel dann
heute hat der ehrwürdige deutsche
historiker tag begonnen und auch dort
gender brand bis der arzt kommt und man
zerstört so das bewusstsein dass fahrer
geworden ist dass sich beliebig gemacht
werden kann man redet nur noch im formel
man wird dadurch immer unverständlicher
es gibt sogar promovierenden programme
das heißt schüler doppelpunkt innen
student doppelpunkt innen um mein
lieblingswort ist ein ganz langes ich
wollte eben schon sagen es ist wirklich
von den deutschen historikern die
vergeben jetzt promovierenden die band
ja doppelpunkt innen also promovierenden
stipendiatin sind auch eingeladen er
sieht die selbstverständlichkeit mit der
diese länder sprach sich durchsetzt
zeigt einfach ist dort ein kulturkampf
im gange und wem es eben um
verständlichkeit zu tun ist der sollte
diesen kampf aufnehmen das ist ein ganz
wichtiges thema das sie da angesprochen
haben frauen mich persönlich beendet das
im zusammenhang mit der kirche also ich
bin ja jetzt nicht katholiken nobody's
perfect ich bin protestant wobei mein
vater war katholik also ich kann das
auch nachempfinden und die kirchen
entfernen sich hier einfach von ihrem
auftrag und der auftrag der kirchen
würde eigentlich darin bestehen das
evangelium zu predigen die bibel
auszulegen die schatzkammer der
menschheit das wichtigste buch das wir
haben aber statt dessen was machen sie
sie haben diese roten waffen auf den
ganzen die da ihre soft
sozialdemokratischen zeitgeist nonsens
auf kosten der steuerzahler darunter
predigen aber es kommt noch schlimmer
jetzt lese ich doch heute in einer
deutschen zeitung die hier nicht
erwähnen möchte weil wir bei der
bildzeitung sehen sondern sich um die
süddeutsche richtig auf der titelseite
jetzt habe der papst und andere
theologen hätten sich jetzt da
zusammengetan um den klimawandel die
bekämpfung des klimawandels zur höchsten
priorität zu erklären das ist für mich
jetzt der gipfel des wahnsinns in der
kirche jetzt eher erdreistet sich die
kirche ermächtigt sich die kirche die
schöpfung zu bewahren dabei tschuldigung
liebe kirchen es gibt da noch einen
schöpfer da draußen ich meine immer die
kirchen würden über themen reden aber
jetzt sitzen die päpste und die
theologen und die pfeifen schon auf dem
thron des schöpfers und wollen die
schöpfung bewahren und der gender stern
ist ein weiteres indiz dafür wie die
einfach vor dem zeitgeist kapitulieren
und das finde ich ein eigentlich
schlimmes thema weil ich finde die
kirchen hätten eine ganz wichtige
funktion in der heutigen gesellschaft
indem sie eben ihren auftrag erfüllen
die schatzkammer der menschheit die
bibel das evangelium die größte story
dies überhaupt möglich und es ist halt
einfach einsatz nur noch dazu es greift
hat dermaßen um sich dass sich das
ändern der gender stern von selbst
versteht er wird nicht mehr begründet
man wird damit einfach zugeschüttet das
ist die normale anrede form vor allem
und das treibt mich eben besonders um
vor allem bei institutionen die
staatlich gefördert sind das heißt sie
werden mit mitteln der gemeinde
allgemeinheit unterliegt und werden dann
geändert und in dem zusammenhang müssen
wir natürlich auch über die
öffentlich-rechtlichen sprechen
die das zumindest teilweise machen
bilder an das 60 bis 70 prozent der
bevölkerung sind aber weiterhin dagegen
ist ja ok ja also das ist so ein
schenkelklopfer wenn ich jetzt ihre
kneipe g und machen china willst dann
hahaha noch ne runde nicht dann freuen
sich alle und alle freuen sich auf die
schenkel und ich hab natürlich die ganze
kneipe für mich sehr billiger applaus
ich gesagt aber
klar ist der home run in der politik 50
ist also über 60 prozent ist home run
ertl mehr geht eigentlich habe ich
insofern kann ich mir die meinung dann
auch zu eigen machen und kann sagen ja
die position vertrete ich mal nur dann
ändert sich nichts wenn alle immer so
denken dass sie bei den zwei drittel
sind ich
finde teile die meinung dass das sehr
angestrengt klingt dieses liebe
freundinnen abermals aussprechen wollen
genau ich habe jetzt personell setzt
auch eine leiterin der sitzung das aus
das war sehr sehr seltsam aber ich habe
überhaupt kein problem mit liebe freunde
und freundinnen liebe pilotin pilot der
schon länger darüber wert sind sind wir
eben nicht weil jede kritik daran die
sie auch so äußern einem respekt aber
macht auch natürlich diese form der
benennung von frauen und männern in
irgendeiner weise madig deswegen finde
ich dass es doch so sein sollte dass wir
uns darauf konzentrieren sollten eine
weibliche oder männliche funktioniert
und es gibt menschen auch die sagen okay
das ist mir irgendwie noch nicht denn
amis ich genug ich nenne irgendwie das
andere aber dem nicht völlig entspannt
und völlig frei und findet das sogar gut
weil es gibt nicht nur piloten es gibt
auch pilotinnen es gibt nicht nur
maskenbildner es gibt auch noch es gibt
kleine rollen im bild nach stern
schienen die gibt ja gut das ist eine
form der kunde man einmal näher mit ihm
in der diskussion auch ein thema von dir
seit vielen jahren kann man das
unternehmen sich habe letztens jemand
versprochen er sich nie mehr den satz
sagen ländern ist anti feministische ich
muss es jetzt aber doch wie den
hausanschluss versprochen dass ich jetzt
nicht aber ich habe sie ja bei mir im
haus versprochen es zu oft gesagt hab
aber das ist der kern wir müssen nicht
darüber reden also erstmal das ist
leider der kern ist musste ich diesen
satz jetzt schon wieder sage ich
entschuldige mich
jetzt schon wieder sagen weil es ist
völlig egal ob man das nicht mag oder
wenn es die sprache verändert dass jen
hat die erst einen ganz tollen
grundgedanken der grundgedanke den finde
ich nämlich übrigens auch nicht lustig
weil der grundgedanke ist wenn alle mit
einbeziehen ob es was ganz neues
das problem ist nur begrenzen damit
frauen schon wieder aus also es gibt
wirklich nichts was mehr anti
feministische seitz ist rändern drei
morgen zeigt man sagt wieder du bist ein
mann du bist eine frau und du bist ne
binär ich war letztens beim podium der
saßen trans freude gesagt ich will
einfach eine frau sein warum muss ich
immer ins trans frau genannt werden und
ehrlich gesagt jubilar wurde letztens
als gäste eingeladen da muss ich dir
ganz ehrlich sagen da habe ich direkt
abgesagt ich habe gar nicht
weitergelesen als bis zum zweiten satz
weil mein problem ich will autor sein
ich will kolumnist sein dürfen und ein
beispiel habe ich noch bevor ich jetzt
hin monolog alte in der schule wenn ihr
lehrer meinte alle schüler raus die als
feueralarm da saß ich glaube da nicht
als mädchen gesagt moment mal sie haben
mich nicht angesprochen also ich werde
mich immer vom schüler angesprochen
gefühlt ich möchte auch gast sein ich
bin heute hier pauls gast und ich will
nicht pauls gestern sein und was du
gesagt hast von wegen naja du findest so
kämen leute zu ändern das geht mir auch
so aber ich kann dir sagen als junge
autorin wie oft ich probleme meiner
laufbahn hatte nicht bei bild aber
woanders weil ich nicht ändern wollte
das war unfassbar was mir für vorwürfe
gemacht wurden ich sah eine schlechte
feministin ich wollte dass meine jüngere
schwester nicht gleichberechtigt
aufwächst und so ein bullshit und
deswegen ist über die ein problem
geworden aber die menge als autorin und
nicht als autor insofern ist es ja gut
dass du diese weiblichen formen
angenommen hat und auch mit ihrer arbeit
aber ist autorin ist ja auch jetzt nicht
nicht nicht nicht autoren gab es auch
schon früher aber ich finde seit den
schwachsinn dass man gestern sein und
was wäre passiert wenn kanzler geblieben
wäre denn wer ist kanzler angela merkel
gewesen das wäre weiblich aufgeladen
worden die form ist eigentlich nämlich
überhaupt nicht weiblich männlich das
gehört euch nicht und sonst müssen wir
auch mal sagen der die blume ich meine
es wird ja immer darauf gedrungen auch
in diesem thema respekt toleranz viel
erhalte so aber das bekommen wir eben
rückmeldungen von bis zu zwei drittel
der bevölkerung die sagen wir wollen das
nicht und trotzdem habe ich keine chance
den zu entkommen speziell bei den
öffentlich-rechtlichen muss noch einmal
sagen die newslettern die app
nachrichten die geschriebene nachricht
sind fast alle komplett eine spannende
frage finde ich vielleicht zu finden
abschluss glaubt ihr wenn es jetzt
koalitionsverhandlungen gibt und die
grünen dort beteiligt sind und dann gibt
es dokumente die angefertigt werden
twitter gesendet oder hast du dann die
fdp ausrutscher also da erwarte ich habe
noch größten widerstand der bild
-zeitung mal hinter diesem senden steht
eine ganz gefährliche ideologie eine
biologistische ideologie die davon
ausgeht dass das geschlecht von menschen
frei gewählt werden kann und das ist
also wirklich auch die kinder ganz übel
was im namen dieser
sprach terroristen aber es gibt auch
viele jugendliche muss ich mal sagen
oder auch ihr habt ihr habt mir unsere
ja ich hab mich das ein bisschen
verharmlost vor ich sage dieses center
dieses gender sprache ist auch ein
ideologischer angriff auf unsere
gesellschaft die wollen uns ein korsett
und sprachlichen biologismus aufzwingen
ich bin das auch gut dass man die frauen
mit denkt aber in dem ich immer betonen
muss auch mit diesen zeichen dass sich
auf der richtigen seite stehen wenn sie
sich wenden herr kessler dann sind sie
ein schlechter mensch diskriminieren
bereit ein sie sind der krise in arabien
entsetzt dass bela anda dafür der
zeitgeist
es ist doch so dass es bestimmte
berufsbilder gab die wahren
traditionellen männern vorbereiten und
es war ein kampf von frauen sich da zu
etablieren nehmen wir den piloten
wenn das nicht nur
weil nicht er nicht die sprache
das
[Musik]